escribe la ecuación de la línea que
tenga la pendiente de un tercio y que
contenga el punto menos 12 - 14 tercios
y bueno la forma de la recta que voy a
escoger es la siguiente que es igual a
mx más b la cual es la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen donde m es la
pendiente y b es la ordenada el origen o
la intersección con el eje de las 10 y
bueno qué datos nos dan lo que nos dan
de datos es que me afecta tiene la
pendiente de un tercio por lo tanto m
vale un tercio y esta cuestión la puedo
reescribir de la siguiente manera y es
igual a un tercio de x + b y bueno lo
siguiente que me dan es un punto y
entonces para que descubra el valor de
ven voy a utilizar este punto que me dan
que por cierto lo que nos dice es lo
siguiente que cuando x vale menos 12 y
vale menos 14 tercios cuando x vale
menos 12 ya vale y déjame ponerlo aquí
menos catorce tercios y entonces ya que
tengo estos dos datos
voy a sustituir los respectivos valores
tanto
como de james y entonces me queda que
menos 14 tercios es igual a un tercio de
equis pero x vale en este punto que
contienen y gráfica es decir en este
punto que está contenido en una recta
vale menos 12 más ven y bueno pues lo
único que hay que hacer es resolver esta
ecuación para ver para encontrar el
valor de b que satisfaga esta línea
recta y entonces pues vamos a hacerlo me
quedan menos 14 tercios es igual a quien
a un tercio por menos 12 menos por más
es menos 2 entre 34 entonces todo esto
se reduce a menos 4 y déjame ponerlo con
color verde menos 4 más ven y mejor
déjame poner a la vez de color amarillo
para que no nos confundamos y quiero
hacer todo con mucha claridad que todo
se entienda paso por paso y bueno ahora
lo que necesito es despejar a ver y para
despejar a ver lo que voy a hacer es
sumar cuatro de ambos lados de la
ecuación para que este 4 se cancele con
un 4 positivo más 4 + 4 y entonces que
me va a quedar del lado derecho menos 4
4 se van y siempre sencillamente me
queda bien mientras que del lado
izquierdo como pero estos dos quebrados
bueno pues para esto lo que voy a hacer
es encontrar un denominador común y
escribir el 4 con base en ese
denominador común que es el 3 y por lo
tanto al 4 lo puedo escribir como 12
tercios este 4 de aquí es exactamente lo
mismo que 12 tercios y entonces me queda
12 tercios menos 14 tercios y quiero ser
muy claro en este paso lo único que hice
fue encontrado el denominador común y
por eso el 4 lo escribí como 12 tercios
y entonces que me quedan 12 tercios
menos 14 tercios esto es lo mismo que
menos dos tercios de entonces es lo
mismo que menos dos tercios y perfecto
porque ya con este valor de b podemos
reescribir esta ecuación y así encontrar
la respuesta de este problema entonces
en lugar de b voy a sustituirlo por el
valor de menos dos tercios y me queda
que es igual a un tercio este un tercio
sale de la pendiente que nos dieron
menos dos tercios porque me vale menos
dos tercios
x dos tercios y ya está hemos encontrado
la ecuación de esta recta